Bienvenidos en 5 minutos donde
intentamos explicar de manera sencilla
asuntos complicados el 8 de noviembre
será una jornada clave en Estados Unidos
los ciudadanos irán a las urnas para las
elecciones de medio término un examen
para el presidente y unos comicios
definitivos para lo que resta de su
mandato
que se elige en las llamadas miterm que
está en juego para Joe biden y cuáles
son los principales temas que mueven a
los selectores El Congreso de Estados
Unidos se compone de la cámara de
representantes y del senado actualmente
los demócratas gozan de mayoría en el
legislativo
controlan 221 de los 435 escaños de la
cámara baja en el senado hay un empate
con 50 escaños para cada partido sin
embargo la vicepresidenta camela Harris
tiene el voto definitivo lo que otorga
una muy frágil mayoría al partido de
gobierno el 8 de noviembre se elegirá la
totalidad de la cámara de representantes
a la vez que 35 escaños del senado
algunos actualmente en poder demócrata y
otros tantos bajo dominio republicano
que podría pasar en las elecciones de
acuerdo a la tendencia de estos comicios
históricamente castigan al presidente de
turno a mitad de su mandato y es muy
posible que los republicanos tomen el
control de la cámara baja solamente
necesitan conquistar cinco escaños para
lograrlo y las encuestas les auguran una
ventaja mucho más amplia pero la pelea
real se centrará en el senado de acuerdo
hombre pronóstico del portal factor los
demócratas tienen dos entre tres
posibilidades de mantener el control e
incluso podrían ampliarlo a un par de
escaños más que está en juego para Joe
biden en pocas palabras el futuro de la
gobernabilidad del país la pérdida de
una sola de las cámaras le complicaría
las cosas por ejemplo el republicano
Kevin mccarthy quien podría convertirse
en presidente de la cámara baja advirtió
que su partido podría recortar la ayuda
financiera para Ucrania y perder el
control del Congreso relegaría al
presidente a un papel obstruccionista
usando su poder de veto para frenar la
agenda republicana gracias a las
estrechas mayorías demócratas en el
primer tramo de su mandato vaiden
cerebro logros legislativos como la ley
de infra la ley de acción contra la
crisis climática o la reciente ley para
reducir la inflación bajo control
republicano sus promesas decodificar el
derecho Federal al aborto o limitar el
uso de rifles de asalto quedarían en el
lodo Cuáles son los principales escaños
en juego por el senado hay varios
estados claves los republicanos van tras
tres territorios ahora en manos
demócratas Arizona Nevada y Georgia en
Georgia compiten el demócrata Rafael
warnock actualmente en el cargo y el
republicano hershey Walker cuya campaña
se ha visto manchada en las últimas
semanas por acusaciones de abuso
doméstico e incluso de haber pagado por
un aborto cuando su campaña ha estado
basada en el rechazo a la interrupción
voluntaria del embarazo
entre tanto los demócratas tienen
puestos sus ojos en Wisconsin y
Pensilvania en este último compiten por
un escaño abierto el vicegobernador John
federman y una estrella de la televisión
el doctor
apoyado por Donald Trump Y es que el
respaldo del ex presidente ha resultado
crucial para los candidatos republicanos
la inmensa mayoría de los que recibieron
su beneplácito ganaron en las consultas
internas muchos de ellos respaldan la
falsa narrativa de que hubo fraude en
las presidenciales de 2020 sin embargo
Aunque la bendición del Magnate funciona
a nivel nacional su popularidad no
supera el 42% según
el ex mandatario ha seguido en el centro
del debate por diversos escándalos e
investigaciones en su contra el
departamento de Justicia lo acusa de
llevarse ilegalmente documentos
clasificados de la Casa Blanca Mientras
que el comité que Investiga la toma al
Capitolio en enero de de 21 lo citó
formalmente a declarar acusándolo de un
rol activo para revertir los legítimos
resultados de 2020
una victoria holgada de los republicanos
podría empoderar a Trump para poner fin
a las especulaciones y anunciar su
candidatura por la reelección en 2024
Qué temas han marcado la campaña por un
lado los demócratas impulsan la defensa
de los derechos reproductivos tras la
histórica de erogación del fallo Row
versus wate amanos de una Corte Suprema
conservadora se presentan como el
partido que defiende la democracia ante
las mentiras de Trump prometen
soluciones para los constantes tiroteos
e impulsan la lucha contra el cambio
climático sin embargo los vientos soplan
a favor de los republicanos Pues los
principales temas de preocupación según
las encuestas son los puntos débiles
deviten la economía y la inflación los
datos inflacionarios son los más altos
en décadas y la reserva Federal sigue
subiendo las tasas de interés lo que
deja al país en riesgo de recesión
además Otro aspecto central de estos
comicios es que la contienda se está
desarrollando con una altísima
polarización con argumentos cada vez más
alejados del lado y lado lo que
evidencia que en Estados Unidos la
división política parece haber llegado
para quedarse
si les sirvió el vídeo para entender las
claves de los esperamos en otro episodio
de en 5 minutos en France 24 y France
24.com
[Música]